with a student Manu we talked about
ribosomes and I was trying to build a
ribosome
um that worked on fluids so that I could
place the little Parts we're talking
about and we it kept failing because
bubbles would come into our system and
the bubbles would make the whole thing
stop working and we spent about half a
year trying to get rid of the bubbles
then Manu said wait a minute the bubbles
are actually
better than what we're doing we should
just use the bubbles and so we invented
how to do Universal object with little
logic with little Bubbles and fluid okay
you have to you have to explain this
microfluidic bubble logic please how
does this work so yeah that's super
interesting yeah and so over so I'll
come back and explain it but what it led
to was we showed fluids could do
um
it'd been known fluid could do logic
like your old automobile transition
Transmissions do logic but that's
macroscopic it didn't work at little
scales we showed with these bubbles we
could do it at little scales that then
I'm going to come back and explain it
but what came out of that is Manu then
showed you could make a 50 Cent
microscope using little Bubbles and then
um the techniques we developed are what
we use to transplant genomes to make
synthetic life all came out of the
failure of trying to make a the genome
the the the ribosome now so the way the
bubble logic works is
um in a little town Channel
uh fluid at small scales is fairly
viscous it's sort of like pushing Jello
think of it as
um
if a bubble gets stuck the fluid has to
detour around it
so now imagine
a channel that has two Wells and one
bubble
if the bubble is in one well the fluid
has to go in the other channel
if the fluid is in the other well it has
to go in the first channel
so the the but the position of the
bubble
can switch
it's a switch it can switch the fluid
between two channels so now we have one
element of switch and it's also a memory
because you can detect whether or not a
bubble is stored there
then if two bubbles meet
um if you have two channels crossing a
bubble can go through one way or a
bubble can go through the other way but
if two bubbles come together then they
push on each other and one goes one way
and one goes the other way that's a
logic operation that's a logic gate so
we now have a switch we have a memory
and we have a logic eight and that's
everything you need to make a universal
computer
I mean the fact that you did that with
bubbles in microfluence just
kind of brilliant well so I mean to stay
with that example uh it it what we
propose to do was to make a fluidic
ribosome and the project crashed and
burned it was a disaster
um this is what came out of it and so it
was
precisely ready fire aim in that we had
to do a lot of homework to be able to
make these microfluidic systems
the the Fire part was we didn't think
too hard about making the ribosome we
just tried to do it the aim part was we
realized the ribosome failed but
something better had happened and if you
look all across research funding
research management
it doesn't
anticipate this so fail fast is familiar
but fail fast tends to miss ready and
aim it can't just fail you have to do
your homework before the fail part and
you have to do the aim part after the
fail part and so the whole language of
research is about like milestones and
deliverables that works when you're
going down a straight line but it
doesn't work for this kind of Discovery
and a leap to something you said that's
really important is I view part of what
the Fab Lab network is doing is giving
more people the opportunity to fail